warning you may never eat bread again
after watching this video now i do know
that even at hinting at this idea of
taking away someone's bread can stir up
a lot of upset emotion resistance etc
but i just want to challenge you to
watch this video
because the question is why do people
love bread so
much i mean what is it about the bread
that is so special that people like so
much well you're about to find out that
there's a huge push to get
everyone on this planet to eat more
grains the problem is we're already
eating too many grains there's a new
term i want to introduce to you called
health washing health washing is a term
to describe
giving certain claims to foods that are
not necessarily true i mean everywhere
you look the grains are natural
they're wholesome
whole grains are a part of a healthy
diet i mean they're high in fiber which
they actually are not as high in fiber
as other foods they're loaded in
vitamins and minerals and we won't talk
about the anti-nutrient called phytase
that blocks those minerals and grains
are heart healthy and they can even help
you lower your your belly fat
but the problem is that most of these
studies are surveys they're
questionnaires they're not peer-reviewed
placebo-controlled clinical trials and
if they are they're industry sponsored
studies the point is that when we're
continually told to consume 6 to 11
servings
of grains as our foundation for our diet
one half of them being whole grains the
other can be refined grains that's a
tremendous amount of carbohydrates that
are introduced to our diet but today i'm
going to talk about just one little tiny
aspect of bread okay i'm not going to
talk about how it turns into sugar and
it can cause weight gain i want to focus
just on this one little thing called
gluten okay now what is gluten gluten
is the protein
in a lot of grains okay especially wheat
and gluten is a term to describe various
proteins within this category and one of
the proteins is called gliadin derived
opioid
peptide okay now what the heck is that
that is a protein that can create an
opioid effect so in other words it can
mimic
morphine to a certain degree now what
are the effects of opioids well right
now we have a major problem
around the world with opiate addiction
synthetic opioids where it literally
like fentanyl destroys people's lives
it's highly addictive so just one thing
an opioid will do is it'll increase
endorphins okay endorphins
are internal body chemicals that make us
feel good
that can help decrease pain okay and our
bodies make endorphins there's another
term i want to introduce to you called
exorphins okay
and exorphin
is an endorphin that can be triggered by
food okay you consume certain things and
it creates an endorphin effect now this
is very important to know because
this is why you like bread so much
bread stimulates endorphins it gives you
this euphoric feeling
it can stimulate appetite that's why
they serve you the bread before your
meal so you'll be hungrier and want to
order more food and so the reason why
people love this bread is because it's
altering our chemistry it's increasing
our endorphins okay now the problem is
that it comes with a little bit of a
package you may have heard the celiac
disease which a person has a severe
reaction of gluten okay in the gi tract
they're going to get the classic
symptoms diarrhea
bloating
and abdominal
pain okay and a lot of other conditions
too like inflammation the gut eventual
atrophy of the little villi or the
little
internal roots on your in your small
intestine that are supposed to help you
absorb
food those become smaller and smaller to
the point where they're just no longer
there so you have a major digestive
problem
and the problem with celiac is it's very
hard to diagnose unless you do a biopsy
and so you may say well
i don't have celiac i don't get diarrhea
bloating abdominal pain when i consume
bread so what's the big deal
well
there's something called non-celiac
gluten sensitivity and this is basically
asymptomatic
celiac in other words a person will have
celiac without the symptoms
of the digestive tract at least without
classical symptoms
diarrhea bloating abdominal pain but
they have other issues okay because the
problem is still occurring at your gut
level
the damage is still being done
on these villi you're getting
inflammation you're getting atrophy that
will eventually show up in other
problems down the road but you may not
experience really any symptoms when you
have bread
but what i want to do is i want to
expand your awareness on some other
symptoms that you may be experiencing
that are connected that you might not
think are connected let's first talk
about the mental connection how it can
affect your mental state well first of
all it can create symptoms like add
depression
anxiety and even autism and i will put
that research down below it can even
lead to things like schizophrenia which
i will put that to study down below as
well
the other problem is a permeability
issue in your gut so you've heard of
leaky gut right well that is a condition
where you have holes in your gut that's
created by the inflammation because
there's so much omega-6
fatty acids in bread and grains like if
we were going to compare omega-3 to
omega-6
it's like 1 to 22 so in other words
there's 22 times more omega-6 fatty
acids than there is omega-3 so there's a
lot of inflammation going on which is
going to create
holes or permeability issues in your
lower gut and when you have holes you
allow proteins to go through and you
create all sorts of immune reactions and
then you create allergies and eventually
autoimmune problems especially of the
thyroid like in hashimoto's and then
another one is psoriasis okay which is
an autoimmune condition so we get damage
to our intestine and then we start
getting malabsorption we no longer
absorb certain things and that leads to
vitamin and mineral deficiencies and a
whole cascade of additional problems
which i'm not going to get into another
common symptom is insomnia which leads
to fatigue you may have brain fog you
may also become anemic because you can't
absorb iron and it can lead to digestive
problems like gerd which is
a severe acid reflux and headaches and
migraines and list goes on and on and on
now sometimes when people live in
america they consume like a pizza for
example and they feel very bloated but
then that bloating goes away and maybe
they go on a trip overseas maybe they go
to italy and they eat a pizza but they
don't react and they're wondering why
can i eat grains in certain countries
but i cannot consume them in
other countries like america well one of
the reasons is that when you ferment
grains to bread
or pizza dough or whatever
the fermentation the microbes actually
eat the protein they start reducing the
gluten considerably so for example
sourdough bread has a lot less gluten as
other breads and this is why they might
not experience the bloating and so in
america the way they make bread is they
don't ferment it for two or three days
they they
maybe ferment it for like an hour or so
and so we retain the gluten so the more
gluten that a grain product has
the more you're going to have a problem
with this now the other point i want to
bring up is that over the years we've
hybrid different grains
like wheat to
have more
gluten okay and this is one additional
problem and then there's also additional
problems too when you enrich um or
fortify these flower products especially
bread with
synthetic vitamins and iron
a lot of people react to that as well
now the point i'm trying to make is that
i'm just taking one aspect of grains and
that's gluten but there's a lot of other
additional problems as well but i think
even when people go off grains and they
start the ketogenic plan one huge reason
why they might even feel so much better
is not even necessarily the lowering of
the carbohydrates it is the abstinence
of eating these grains
that
eliminate
a lot of the inflammation that is going
on in the gut and then all the
associated symptoms
so
i want to challenge you just to
avoid eating bread okay for one week
okay in fact avoid all grains for one
week and just see how you feel
then the next week go back to eating
bread and grains and then see how you
feel and then compare these two and then
decide whether it's worth it or not now
if you have not seen my video
on
sugar and how that affects the red blood
cell that's a real interesting video i'm
going to put that one up right here
check it out
you